[Música]
o futuro do o outro é o mesmo que na
equipe é vergonha dizia pensar fora da
caixa
[Música]
a linha faz alguém escreveu isto é não é
isso que eu tenho para te contar é muito
mais do que pensar fora da caixa
nani bushel bonecos marionetes a arte da
vida um objeto
interessante não teatro de marionetes
trabalhar como neco
ai como podendo para sério é dizer que
trabalha com bonecos
o que à partida supostamente seria um
homem algo muito sério
exato foi o que aconteceu isso
paixão pelo fado tem de ser inabalável
[Música]
ele tem que acreditar em mim e no teu
projecto isso mesmo
mesmo que seja usado por todos à sua
volta sem blusa onde alguns médicos
seria mentira dizer que tudo é fácil w
mas na verdade não é assim tão fácil
seja ignorado em casa mas podem inverter
as coisas e fazer os conquistar 10 sejam
objetivos a pensar no fundo é sempre uma
questão de instantes da casa não fazem
milagres jovem não falar isto já é
medeira isso mesmo é mentira fazem
senhor são eles que fazem os milagres
são os que têm que ser apoiados
uma força de um lugar do país nunca ao
todo segurar nos mais próximos em que
vamos acreditar
estudamos aprendemos prejudicar muito
muito muito nunca desistir foi o que
fizemos
e claro com a assistência foi o
conhecimento
primeiro as ora ora veja mas karen
também ama já um pouco fora da caixa
e como queremos chegar é mais público
tivemos que sair daqui e começar a
procurar outras soluções técnicas
estéticas como por exemplo mário netas
de fios em elton não usassem daí que
agora vão aparecer mesmo delegado
alexandre miguel que ainda não concedeu
elas têm os filhos indígenas não estão
vivos um boneco ok por exemplo mário
neto dizer é ontem um cidadão sem assim
como eu tenho aqui na música podem fazer
isso bem é de 73 e misturar e reinventar
porque na área neta ganha vida é isso a
vida certo então vocês agora fugido para
isso também vai bem mas eu ficar no
mesmo sítio não chegava então como anda
a fazer as pessoas façanha sério neste
mercado tão pequeno que o teatro do
teatro de bonecos
a solução flui na procura de novos
espaços e um já na parte da construção é
tomar agora
é isso ai vai
depois de implementarmos várias soluções
veteranos com outro problema é a única
céu é verdade o diálogo é a língua e se
rendam quem quiser viajar e queremos
mostrar a nossa arte outros povos
mas para isso tenhamos de comunicar
mantivemos a técnica e tiramos as
palavras até isso
assim podemos comunicar sempre seja com
quem for e se fizermos com humor ainda
melhor acomodar papa é frank
ai ai
assim foi o nosso grande pilar eu vi
toda esta comunicação quem é que existam
ser como eu lhe parra rock mário netas
manipulação viver este criarem valor é
de defender o grande segredo da técnica
é precisamente a surpreender seu público
não está à espera em esse grandes grito
surdo
[Música]
ah
assim
[Música]
hum